LOL SkyMall magazine this is Riyaz
speaking hello Riyaz I would like to
report an item which I ordered that
arrived broken Linda Sanders Mockingbird
Lane
that's right showing the last item that
do you received is the Superman bed with
the mattress of Solitude
that's the one ordered it from a son for
his birthday but I cannot give it to him
like this and i'm pretty darn-tootin
pissed about it I will start processing
your reorder right now with you on the
line okay I ain't mad at you Riyaz it's
just the system I now okay thank you for
understanding sir kids eh huh oh okay
well yeah I just got the one myself had
sex with a woman and everything to get
them how long is this gonna teach your
son's name Oh Stimpy pretty much Stimpy
I have boys too
I tell you sometimes they can be a real
couple of universe [ __ ] [ __ ]
stupid don't you give me that look
you're gonna get it when your mama comes
home
oh my son's like your wife is [ __ ] on
wheels you got that straight Riaz hot
little biscuit though name's Claire Body
ten face ten so pretty much hit dad
every night sexually anyway what's one
more minute and how old is her son 15
and he still wants a Superman bed enjoy
it while you still can
he'll grow out of the toys any day now
start hooking up with the girls you
forget all about that Superman and
spider-man stuff pretty much seems like
how it would happen maybe then he'll
stop bothering me with all those stupid
little facts about how those characters
you just named are clearly from two
distinct
separate universes some people never
move on sad I got a better word for you
pathetic hey I calls them likes i sees
em Riyaz and I Donst tolerate nerds in
fact let me nip this in the bud real
quick Stimpy Stimpy get back in here I
didn't clear you with the brown body and
your creepy-ass face no more sweets for
you cuz you're never gonna get laid if
you keeps eating sweets all these
figurines and toys you got around the
house we're throwing them in the trash
cuz they're not real people Stimpy
they're not real people - stop being so
lonely stop pants so love me then and
this is none of my business of course
but I was wondering if your jumped out
the window oh my god oh I killed himself
why to do it it must have been my fault
no it wasn't yes it was I'm gonna call
the cops don't you dare cancel that
reorder it's the only thing I'll have to
remember him by
you